i never want to hear that trump is
demeaning toward women
or sexist against women or misogynistic
or whatever again i don't want to hear
it
because there's a song called whap is it
whap or wap i don't know
this is put out here by an artist named
cardi b i know that
ben got in trouble for this the other
day because ben just read the lyrics
of this disgusting song that's probably
the most disgusting song i've ever heard
this is actual audio pornography which i
didn't know could exist
ben got in trouble for it so you know
obviously we've got to
get into it here i thought i didn't even
watch ben's clip
but people were very upset that he was
calling this out so i it made me go and
listen to the song
this thing is so obscenely degrading to
women but that's not just that's not the
only point i have to make about it
if that were it you know look that's rap
music right music is always degrading to
women
the the point about this is the
degradation
of the individual and the degradation of
american society and the degradation
of our interpersonal relations so the
song begins i'll have to clean this up
as i go i suppose
it opens up with a repeated line there's
some [ __ ] in this house
sung by a woman she's very proud of this
she's accepting her identity as
a [ __ ] she's reveling in that
spit in my mouth look in my eyes saying
you know degrade me i want to be
degraded and i want you to acknowledge
that you are degrading me while you do
it i don't cook
i don't clean but let me tell you how i
got this
ring a a i'm skipping around to just
the lines that i think really tell you
something here beyond the
the language of most of it is so
disgusting i certainly can't read it on
the show
but listen to that i don't cook i don't
clean
but let me tell you how i got this ring
what she's saying is
marriage is transactional no man would
want to marry a woman because he loves
her
because there is something lovable about
her because he wants to give of himself
to her
a man would only marry a woman to get
something
and so what could what could he get well
the traditional model that we're
rejecting
is that you know men marry women so they
can cook and clean for them
but what this enlightened empowered
woman is saying is no i we don't do that
that would be degrading
this man condescended to marry me
because i do filthy sexual acts on him
all the time
and i allow him to degrade me so that's
and that's why this is much more
empowered
now of course this is a caricature of
what marriage used to be
marriage was not merely a fact of you go
and you hire a woman
to cook and clean for you there's a
little aspect of that but
more it's about giving yourself to the
other person in this union
for life but because of that progressive
misunderstanding of the past
which you know the past has to be awful
so things always have to be worse in the
past
and things we also apply this highly
economic
model of how of interpersonal relations
very selfish model of interpersonal
relations we we apply that retroactively
in the past
even as we reject it so she's viewing
the the past through that lens
but then because now we're all
enlightened and everything's about sex
she's saying no no
it's much more empowering that i i
conned my husband into marrying me by
performing a lot of strange things on
his body
ask for a car while you ride that
thingy i don't know i won't use uh i
won't use her language
ask for a car right as in
i'm not doing this to my husband because
i love him he's not doing it to me
because he loves me
this is just transactional but don't
forget we're not talk you know it says
there's some [ __ ] in this house
what what cardi b is saying here
fundamentally is that
the relations between the sexes are
are transactional and and we all women
are [ __ ] i mean that's that's the
point here
is even even with your husband you are
engaging in something that is no
different from prostitution
uh another line here he bought a phone
just for pictures
of this uh particularly desirable
genitalia again she uses different words
he bought a phone for it so she's kind
of tricked him into spending money to
a third party right to this
kind of capitalist culture some company
to turn me into a porn
actress so that he can then go away from
me
and do whatever he's going to do to
himself looking at these pictures
right it's it's you're divorcing you're
making it so transactional
that by the end of that line the woman's
not even there anymore
she's not even the one performing the
sex acts she has become
nothing more than a commodity that you
are using not you know
you're not just using her to get a
thrill in person you're using her to get
a thrill in perpetuity
on yourself pay my tuition just to kiss
me on this
desirable genitalia now make it rain
if you want to see some desirable
genitalia put me through school
don't put me through school to make me
better to you know edify me
so that we can have this wonderful life
together no no it's just a kind even
education
here is just about getting something
over on the other person
the way we think of love and education
traditionally is
it makes us better it's a positive good
but not here it's all a zero-sum game
for the left
and then this this line oh my gosh
switch my wig
make him feel like he cheating put him
on his knees
give him something to believe in there
it is switch my wig
meaning i'm going to dress up like i'm
not me i'm going to be
somebody else and this is going to
excite
my husband it's going to make him desire
me because my husband is getting
tired of me he no longer desires me this
kind of cheap transactional sex
has run its course so now i'm going i'm
going to get even more perverse
i'm going to pretend like i'm some other
other woman and that will finally excite
him a little bit more at least for now
and then the key put him on his knees
give him something to believe in
because he he believes in nothing she
believes in nothing none of these people
believe in anything
beyond the satisfaction of their own
selfish appetites and desires
and so she will make an idol out of not
just herself but a very particular part
of herself
and this will finally give him something
to believe in it's an acknowledgement
actually
that man is fundamentally a religious
being it's an acknowledgement that we
want something that is beyond this world
that is beyond the satisfaction of our
selfish desires
but we have no outlet for that we don't
know we don't even know how to talk
about that anymore
and so the nearest we can get is
audio pornography to to describe
a way to trick your senses into
believing that you've transcended that
appetite
and and given given in to something
higher
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]